what really started to catapult you then
let's get to that save me
yeah yeah there was a lot of like this
is what i tell people everything i did
was a step on the ladder
save me was like skipping 10 steps on
the ladder yeah you know i know your
story and you save me now it even it
it's more it means it's under more yeah
it's like i could bore you with like
every little step that helped and there
was so many
everything mattered is what i tell
people everything you're going through
right now in your career if you're a
young up and aspiring artist comedian or
whatever every one of those little
things matter and then there's like a
small tipping point that happens like
the malcolm gladwell book where [ __ ]
just kind of the save me for me will
always be that moment of like
you know what it's fun i don't know how
it is in your business but it's always
the [ __ ] you don't think is going to be
it yeah dude we [ __ ] wrote save me on
a sunday we recorded save me on a monday
we shot a video to some no but we were
quoted saturday recorded it sunday shot
the video monday put it out tuesday
wow
that's how that worked
didn't think twice about it
and did you know that it would be that
you did you know did you have an inkling
you honestly do you have any idea i just
knew that i couldn't quit [ __ ] with
it
i just knew that it was something about
it that just stirred my spirit
and i was like hype just man we gotta go
for it and i just
i was proud of it i was like to me it
was like a therapy session publicly
you know and that was like the biggest
thing for me was like just letting those
emotions out
in a public way was like i don't know
some songs i have songs theo that i
wrote that mean a lot to me that i'll
never play anybody ever because they
mean that much to me
and save me was one of those songs that
could have been that song but it meant
even more to me so it was like now this
one needs to go out like
i just i don't know man i was just
prepared for it to i i loved it so much
i didn't care what it did
if it popped or flopped i just felt like
[ __ ] you know i get thousands of
emails a year of people who say or
messages a year that say your music
helped me
i overcame drug addiction i was going to
kill myself and i found your music i was
literally i've had messages that were
like
i was sitting there gun loaded listening
to a playlist that was going to be the
last listening of my life and found a
song of yours that made me feel like man
this is it touched me in such a way
that it changed my decision and this is
my thing if i get
5 000 of those a year
and 4
999 of them are lies
holy [ __ ] can you believe we saved one
[ __ ] human
you know what i mean like let's just
assume everybody's full of [ __ ] but one
[ __ ] guy
holy [ __ ] man you know what i mean
at the end of the day
that's what save me was about it was
like man
what means the most to me and that's why
i write the music i write is people come
up to me and oh dude
such and such was fun i love that song i
danced to it but when people come up to
you and say dude we played save me at my
cousin's funeral that overdosed
and it's now his mother's favorite song
and the way she copes with it or we
played smoking section at this funeral
or
we played smoking section to commemorate
this or hey man this song helped me when
i got out of rehab yeah
that [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] what this shit's about dude you
know what i mean like when a
motherfucker's like dude i don't just
watch your podcast for humor it was the
[ __ ] first thing i laughed at after i
got out of [ __ ] sobriety
like that's the [ __ ] that touches the
soul you know what i mean
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one